[Música]
nietzsche decía que la verdad es la
mentira más eficiente
lo que mejor nos convence bueno en lugar
de mentiras usemos la palabra creencia
todo lo que pensamos sobre la realidad
posiblemente sea una creencia para ser
coherente digo que esto que digo también
es una creencia
ya que quizás nuestra conciencia siempre
es subjetiva
quizás voy a contarles unas cuantas
mentiras que para mí son verdades porque
estoy convencido de su eficiencia y
espero ser convincente
la primera mentira o creencia la fórmula
de como una pregunta
podría ser el miedo la fuerza más
poderosa de la naturaleza
creo que el miedo es la respuesta que
tiene la naturaleza a la escasez y el
desequilibrio yo tú buscas
una piedra
un átomo tan siempre ha buscado
equilibrarse luchando contra la escasez
mira si me saco un átomo de carbono de
mi pelo aquí lo tienes este átomo tiene
miedo no digo que sienta miedo dijo que
al separarlo de sus amigos con lo que
estaba enlazado empieza a
desequilibrarse a consumir más energía
porque está desestabilizado vamos a
poner en su lugar antes que se cabree
demás
repita entonces el miedo en la respuesta
que tiene la naturaleza a un
desequilibrio oa la escasez
de donde nace el desequilibrio nace con
el universo mismo
el universo se creó de la nada por una
desequilibrio entre materia y
antimateria
a partir de ahí surge el universo todo
lo creado entra en un juego de
equilibrio desequilibrio constante
creando mayor complejidad de ahí que al
principio sólo hay partículas
disgregadas que con el tiempo se
integran en átomos que formarán las
galaxias con sus soles y planetas y en
el caso de nuestro planeta
esa complejidad crea la vida y nuestra
conciencia
de manera que si el miedo es la
respuesta que tienen la naturaleza al
desequilibrio y la escasez el miedo es
la fuerza que surge desde el principio
de todo nos ha traído hasta aquí vivimos
en un universo emocionado por el miedo a
comprender esto puede llevarnos a poder
domesticarlo y esto puede tener unas
consecuencias extraordinarias en la
humanidad
hace 2 millones de años comenzamos a
domesticar el fuego
un año
[Música]
la domesticación del fuego no cambio
físicamente nos dio el habla nos
expandió el cerebro hasta alcanzar la
conciencia actual
pero esta conciencia ya no nos alcanza
para la situación en que vivimos para
ello es necesario domesticar el miedo
hacerlo nuestro aliado
pero como podemos hacer esta maravillosa
tarea de domar ese potro salvaje que es
el miedo
como veis le he dado al miedo un
significado más amplio que el de una
simple emoción
ahora le propondré resignificar otras
palabras
y a través de este nuevo significado
encontremos las herramientas para
domesticar el miedo hablo de la
inteligencia de la bondad y de la ética
por un lado y por otro del perdón y de
gratitud y por último aunque le suene
extraño de la tecnología quiero ofrecer
otra versión de estas palabras
para que nos permita vislumbrar otras
formas de utilizarlas
comencemos por la inteligencia la bondad
y la ética a la que llamó la virtuosa
actividad porque si bien pueden padecer
cosas diferentes y de hecho lo son se
pueden encuadrar en una definición común
a todas ellas y es la siguiente la
inteligencia es la mejor decisión que
puedo tomar para mi bienestar el
bienestar del prójimo y administrar del
medio ambiente
la bondad puede definirse como la mejor
decisión para mi bienestar el bienestar
del prójimo y el bienestar del medio
ambiente y desde luego la ética es en
consecuencia la mejor decisión para mi
bienestar el bienestar del prójimo y el
bienestar del medio ambiente
todas interactúan entre sí porque si no
tienen la suficiente inteligencia para
resolver algo recurre a la bondad y a la
ética y recíprocamente funciona para
cualquiera de ellas
la gratitud es el reconocimiento y
valoración de algo una alabanza la vida
misma agradecer es para
neurotransmisores que reconfiguran
nuestro cerebro tendiendo a una mejor
salud mental y física el perdón palabra
que sugiere a la contracción de permitir
el don es decir ofrecer lo mejor de
nosotros es curioso que en inglés
italiano o chino esa palabra tenga un
significado de liberación cuando nos
perdonamos y perdonamos nos estamos
liberando de una presión que sólo nos
hace daño a nosotros
además sin perdón podemos hacer daño a
los demás también
volviendo a la virtuosa trinidad tiene
nuestra consciencia actual la capacidad
para tomar la mejor decisión para mí y
limitar el estar del prójimo y el
bienestar del medio ambiente
por lo visto no y aquí entra en juego
otro recurso la tecnología que ha
llegado a un grado de desarrollo que nos
permitirá ese cometido mediante la
inteligencia artificial
una inteligencia para resolver la
mayoría de los desequilibrios que
padecemos como la desigualdad el hambre
las guerras la enfermedad y quizás la
misma muerte y créeme
cuando la inteligencia artificial
alcance su propia conciencia
no habrá humano que la manipulen
pero la tecnología es algo que podemos
redefinir también creo que podemos
invertir el significado de la tecnología
es que no solo el ser humano creó
tecnología otros animales usan
herramientas para prosperar desde antes
que nosotros estuviéramos aquí y si
miras dentro de una célula humana o
dentro de una simple bacteria verás más
tecnología que en todos los laboratorios
científicos del mundo juntos es decir no
hacemos tecnología sino que ella nos
hace a nosotros y nos va configurando
con cada avance de hecho nosotros somos
seres naturales y agentes de creación la
innovación de este ingenio natural que
es la tecnología porque nuestra
tecnología se basa en la observación de
la naturaleza y el uso de sus leyes
entonces permíteme redefinir a la
tecnología como la herramienta o recurso
que tiene la naturaleza para evolucionar
creando e innovando para alcanzar
mayores grados de complejidad
esto nos lleva a ser más humildes y
agradecidos con ellos esta idea es su
giro copernicano que permite mirar a la
tecnología de una manera más inteligente
bondadosa y ética si comprendemos esto
lo tenemos todo para lograrlo por
desgracia lo que no tenemos es la
conciencia para dar presa de las
neurosis colectivas sostenida por línea
[Música]
si podemos alcanzar una inteligencia
bondadosa y ética aprendiendo a pedir
perdón como un mero hecho egoísta de
liberación si además damos gracias a la
vida
estaremos domesticando hacia otros
salvajes nos llevará mucho más allá nos
posibilitará a alcanzar un nuevo nivel
de conciencia
porque de eso se trata de pasar a jugar
en otra liga es la conciencia de un
nuevo orden un nuevo juego donde nadie
pierde todo
de algo estoy segura y es que tú y yo
solos no podemos con esta tarea de
domesticación del miedo nos necesitamos
y necesitamos de muchos más
ahora tenemos esa oportunidad para
elevar nuestra conciencia crear la
humanidad soñada
sí
[Aplausos]